en una rara visita fuera de kiev el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
con pruebas de primera mano la
destrucción de mi cola y se encontró con
una ciudad en luto justo el día antes de
que dos personas murieron y 20
resultaron heridas por los bombardeos
rusos en la agenda de su visita el
restablecimiento del suministro de agua
uno de los muchos problemas que aquejan
la ciudad devastada por la guerra a
cientos de kilómetros de distancia en
lysychansk devastada por el conflicto es
una historia similar los combates han
cortado los suministros básicos los
soldados ucranianos que luchan por
mantener en el margen a las fuerzas
rusas dicen que las armas son la
prioridad
necesitamos equipamiento serio y
necesitamos más tanques por el momento
estamos recibiendo equipamiento para los
soldados de infantería como resultado
tenemos que luchar en una guerra de
guerrillas
o por robo moscú ha concentrado su
potencia de fuego en la captura de luis
sanz y su ciudad hermana silver del msk
los últimos focos de resistencia en
lugar
porque el enemigo en la dirección de
severodonezk continúa el fuego de
artillería está apuntando a múltiples
lanzadores de cohetes en nuestras
posiciones así como a la infraestructura
civil cerca del isi chance
moscú dice que se está acercando a sus
objetivos afirmando que ha tomado la
mitad de danielle y casi todo lugansk
dos regiones que conforman en donbass
quien dice que las tropas rusas han
sufrido importantes pérdidas ucrania
también está de luto por los soldados
caídos cientos de personas se reunieron
en la capital para despedir a román
ratas ni una activista de 24 años que
murió mientras luchaba contra las
fuerzas rusas en el donbass saltó a la
fama tras convertirse en uno de los
primeros estudiantes en protestar
durante el maidán en 2014